Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先和大家分享一件现在正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家的准心理学人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Mary Andrews Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。请访问我的 Linktree 链接（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。主讲人：玛丽安·安德鲁斯博士。嗨，欢迎收看《有志心理学家播客》。
It's really important when we're working with people as aspiring psychologists or beyond that we understand just how important the early stages of life are and the early stages of bonding and attachment and nurturance between caregivers and newborns and someone who has specialised in this over recent years is Professor Amy Brown. She's a psychologist, an author, a researcher. She specializes in researching infant feeding, maternal mental health and public health. She has published a number of books on this topic as well, and all of them are just wonderful. I hope that you will find this episode to be really useful in helping you think about any key and pertinent issues around this key stage of development and how and why it's important for us to understand this theory
作为有志心理学家或在相关领域工作时，我们非常需要理解生命早期、早期的依恋与亲密关系，以及照顾者与新生儿之间的滋养有多么重要。近年来专门研究这一领域的专家是艾米·布朗（Amy Brown）教授。她是一位心理学家、作家兼研究员，专注于研究婴儿喂养、母婴心理健康和公共卫生。她围绕这个主题出版了多本著作，每一本都非常精彩。我希望你会发现这期节目非常有用，它能帮助你思考关于这一关键发展阶段的任何核心和相关议题，以及为什么在我们追求心理学职业生涯的过程中，理解这种理论和
and this practice as we go through our career in psychology. So I just want to welcome along Professor Amy Brown who is an all-round research genius in my eyes. Welcome along, Amy. Thank you for having me. You're more than welcome. So I thought it might be useful for us to think a little bit about your journey with research. And also feel free to say what you do currently as well. Oh, gosh. currently as well? Oh gosh, so I'm a Professor of Child Public Health at Swansea University
这种实践对我们如此重要。因此，我热烈欢迎艾米·布朗教授，在我眼中，她是一位全方位的研究天才。欢迎你，艾米。谢谢你邀请我。非常欢迎。所以我想，了解一下你的研究历程可能会对我们很有帮助。同时，也欢迎你随时谈谈你目前在做的工作。噢，天哪。目前在做的工作？噢天哪，我是斯旺西大学的儿童公共卫生教授，
where actually I've been since my undergraduate. I'm one of those very lucky researchers who did their undergraduate, their master's, their PhD at the same university and also then managed to get several jobs at the university. So it is possible, You don't necessarily have to move around if anybody tells you that. So I run a research centre. I run a master's programme. I have numerous PhD students and different research projects. And then I also did quite a lot of writing in terms of media articles and engagement with the media. I run a website and I've written, I think it's 10 books. I've actually lost track at this stage. So I think it's 10, all about the research that I do, but trying to make it accessible for those who read it. So my research is into early parenting
实际上我从本科起就一直留在这里。我是那些非常幸运的研究人员之一，在同一所大学完成了本科、硕士和博士学位，之后还设法在学校谋得了好几份工作。所以这是可能的，如果有任何人告诉你必须到处跳槽，那并不是真的。我管理着一个研究中心，运营一个硕士项目，带了众多博士生并负责不同的研究项目。此外我还写了相当多的媒体文章，并积极参与媒体互动。我经营着一个网站，写了——我想大概有10本书吧。说实话，到这个时候我都记不清了。所以我想大概是10本，都是关于我做的研究，但尽量让读者觉得通俗易懂。所以我的研究方向是早期育儿
experiences and birth and pregnancy and feeding babies and mental health in particular. And it's about writing guides for parents, health professionals, and just those people who work in that area. I just want to say thank you, really, because I think your books are incredible. You know, I first picked up Breastfeeding Uncovered when I was feeding my eldest, who's now eight and a half. And I just never read anything like it before you know it was on my side it was humorous and it was evidence-based you know you're really funny I think I think that I think that helps you know and it also you know inspired me to think about putting my own books together to get my you know words out there and so I just think you I just think you're incredible
经历、分娩、怀孕、婴儿喂养，特别是心理健康。这关乎为父母、健康专业人士以及那些在相关领域工作的人编写指南。我只想说声谢谢，真的，因为我觉得你的书太不可思议了。你知道的，我第一次拿起《揭秘母乳喂养》（Breastfeeding Uncovered）是在喂养我的大女儿时，她现在八岁半了。我以前从来没读过这样的书，你知道的，它就在我床头，既幽默又基于实证，你知道的，你真的很风趣，我觉得，我觉得这很有帮助，而且它也激励我去思考把自己的书整理出版，把我的心声表达出来，所以我只想说，我觉得你太了不起了，
Amy. Thank you it's about that gap that I think sometimes you have practitioners and writers who are outside academia and clinical practice and they write books in a certain way and then you have sort of academics and practitioners who might be very, very evidence based. And it it tends to be excellent. It's really, you know, research driven, but it's more challenging to read as a textbook or, you know, a seminal text on a subject. So it's what I try to do is kind of bridge that gap so that it's really evidence basedbased and it's supported by lots of references and research but you can sit on the sofa on a Sunday evening and read it or you can download it on Audible and take it on your dog walk with you want it to be accessible really I think that's the key word in it all and it really is you do it effortlessly you know I have said before that breastfeeding uncovered is one of my favourite books on any topic, not even just kind of infant nutrition.
艾米。谢谢你，这正是关于那种差距，我觉得有时候你会发现，有些从业者和作家游离于学术界和临床实践之外，他们写书的方式有一种特定的风格；然后你会看到一些学者和从业者，他们可能非常非常注重实证。这往往很优秀，确实是以研究为驱动，但作为教材或某个主题的开创性文献，读起来更有挑战性。所以，我尝试做的是弥合这种差距，让内容既有坚实的实证基础，有大量参考文献和研究支持，但你又可以在周日晚上舒舒服服地坐在沙发上阅读，或者在 Audible 上下载它，带着它去遛狗。我希望它能做到平易近人，真的，我想这就是所有这些的核心关键词。你确实做得毫不费力，你知道的，我以前就说过，《揭秘母乳喂养》是我关于任何主题的最爱书籍之一，甚至不仅仅局限于婴儿营养。
But, you know, what you do really works and it really matters. Actually, your first year of parenting book, I think, should be given out to people with, you know, with their Emma's diary or whatever, you know, because it's so useful. And actually, I would have been much kinder on myself as a parent had I read it. So I was definitely in in the attachment parenting camp and I read it. Is it a lovely book by a doctor? Is it doctors? His stuff felt like real real sort of soul food as a parent. But actually, yours is so much more compassionate. And, you know know I just really like I just really like it I even like the yellow pages in it like so you know what you do what you do
但是，你所做的事情确实奏效，而且意义重大。其实，你的《第一年育儿》（First Year of Parenting）那本书，我觉得应该在人们拿到“艾玛日记”（Emma's Diary）之类的育儿手册时就发给他们，因为它太有用了。事实上，如果我早点读到它，作为父母，我对自己的态度会温和得多。所以我当时绝对属于依恋育儿阵营，我也读过那本书。那是某个医生写的好书吗？是医生写的吗？他的作品作为父母的读物，感觉就像真正的精神食粮。但实际上，你的书要富有同情心得多。而且，我真的非常喜欢它，我甚至喜欢里面黄页部分的内容，所以，你知道的，你所做的事情、
matters and you're somehow you know you're doing it you're bridging that gap between textbook and freaking useful stuff I think it's I think I to myself. I think I write what I needed 15 years ago. And I know what new parents need, because I've been there three times. And I think that when you have some distance from that, you start being able to be more open. So you can admit that things were really tough, or that some days you really didn't like it or you could admit all those thoughts you had in your head about running away and never coming back and that parents often say to me on social media it's like it's like how do you know this about me like it's some sort of magic and it's like no no you you just basically are me but sort of 10-15 years behind me that's all definitely definitely we've all had those moments of hiding as we go and eat something
你所做的工作意义重大，而且不知怎么的，你正在弥合教科书与极其有用的实用干料之间的差距。我想我经常对自己说：我写的是我15年前真正需要的东西。而且我知道新手父母需要什么，因为我已经经历过三次了。我认为，当你与那段时期保持一定距离时，你会开始变得更加坦诚。所以你可以承认事情真的很艰难，或者有些日子你真的不喜欢它，或者你可以承认脑海中那些想逃跑、再也不回来的想法。父母经常在社交媒体上对我说：“这就好像你怎么知道我心里在想什么？这就像某种魔法一样。”而我的回答是：“不，不，你其实就是我，只是比我落后了10到15年而已，仅此而已。”确实，确实，我们都曾在躲起来偷吃东西的时候有过那些时刻，
to hide from our children to like have a moment to decompress and just feeling like you know who's who's let me be the grown-up with these children you know who said I can do this because I think we need a recount here how did you get started in so I love that you actually you know our dads told us growing up there was no such thing as a job for life these days but you are you're disproving that certainly in Swansea how did you get started in academia oh gosh right so when I was an undergraduate student like many psychology students I wanted to be a clinical psychologist and it's almost a funny story it's kind of in hindsight that I think you end up where you're meant to be so I really wanted to be a clinical psychologist but I'm also a person who really absorbs other people's emotions
为了躲避孩子而偷得片刻喘息，感觉自己就像是在问：“到底是谁让我在这些孩子面前当大人的？谁说我可以胜任这个？”因为我觉得我们需要重新数一数人数。你是怎么开始的？所以，我也很喜欢你提到的——虽然大人们在成长过程中告诉我们，如今没有所谓的“铁饭碗”这种工作，但你却在打破这种说法，至少在斯旺西是这样的。你是怎么走上学术道路的？哦天哪，好吧。所以当我还是个本科生时，和许多心理学专业学生一样，我想成为一名临床心理学家。现在回想起来，这几乎是一个有趣的巧合，你会发现自己最终走上了命中注定的道路。我非常想成为一名临床心理学家，但我也是一个对别人的情绪感同身受的人，
really really strongly so I get quite distressed if friends are distressed. You know, I watch TV and I'm feeling everything. And I thought, OK, right, hang on. I don't think you're going to be able to cope with clinical psychology. You're just going to be a mess the whole time. So I thought I'd go into that really non-emotive field of research. And I kind of started on the edges of nutrition research. So I was really interested in childhood nutrition and mental health, kind of more broadly. But I was going to do my PhD on, I can't even remember what it was meant to be on though. I think it was feeding older children. So it's older children's diet around emotional feeding practices so the idea
反应极其强烈，所以如果朋友感到痛苦，我也会感到相当痛苦。你看电视时，我会对一切感同身受。当时我想：“好吧，等一下，我觉得你可能应付不了临床心理学。你整个人会一直处于崩溃状态。”所以我想，不如去涉足那个非情感领域的科研领域吧。我从营养学研究的边缘开始起步。因此，我对儿童营养和心理健康产生了浓厚的兴趣，范围更广一些。但我的博士论文原本打算做的是——我甚至不记得当时具体要做什么了。我想是关于喂养较大儿童的。所以是关于大龄儿童的饮食与情感喂养实践的关系，也就是那个理念：
that you know not bribing children with food not rewarding them with food like all good plans um about a week into that phd i realized that i was pregnant with my first baby and this you know this is a whole other kind of theme of this you know as people told me then oh that's the end of your career in academia are you going to come back to it you're never going to manage with one baby so I had three instead just to prove them wrong but I became fascinated by the experience of maternity care so infant feeding in particular because all the way through pregnancy people kept telling me that breastfeeding was really, really important and you must do it. And it was, you know, really important for the baby and
你知道的，不要用食物贿赂儿童，不要用食物奖励他们，就像所有好的计划一样……大约在那个博士项目开始的一周后，我意识到我怀上了第一个孩子。然后，这引发了另一类关于这个话题的讨论：正如当时人们对我说的那样，“哦，你的学术生涯到此结束了，你还会回来吗？你带着一个孩子是绝对撑不下来的。”所以我索性生了三个，就为了证明他们是错的。但我开始对孕产护理的体验着迷，特别是婴儿喂养，因为整个孕期人们一直告诉我母乳喂养非常非常重要，你必须这样做。而且它对婴儿和
yourself. And then I had that baby and I realised that actually a lot of the support and care around feeding your baby and your own mental health was missing. And I kept meeting other mothers like you do when you've you've got a baby you go to the baby group and when they saw me breastfeeding they would always tell me their story and it was usually something along the lines of they really wanted to but their baby fed too much or they couldn't get the support they needed and it was like they kept having to justify but there were all these myths around feeding so they keep telling me oh I couldn't feed because of x and I think well that's not you know with the right support you might have been able to to feed them so I just became fascinated in the whole issue of
你自己都非常重要。然后我有了那个孩子，我意识到实际上关于喂养婴儿以及你自身心理健康的很多支持和关怀都是缺失的。我不断遇到其他母亲，就像你生了孩子后去婴儿小组时那样，当她们看到我在哺乳时，总是会跟我讲她们的故事，通常的内容是：她们真的很想坚持，但宝宝吃得太多了，或者她们无法获得所需的支持。这就好像她们一直在为自己辩解，但周围充斥着各种关于喂养的迷思。所以她们总是对我说：“哦，我没法喂养是因为X原因。”而我想：“不对，如果有正确的支持，你本可以做到喂养。”所以我开始对整个问题着迷：
barriers to breastfeeding and the lack of support and then subsequently the impact upon mental health which is where we come full circle because I've ended up doing so much research now into the grief and the trauma and the increased risk of postnatal depression that comes alongside not being able to meet your own feeding goals so not being able to breastfeed for as long as you wanted to experience lots of pain and difficulty. And of course, the level of emotion and grief and just distress that goes alongside all of that is immense. So, you know, you have 20 year old me deciding, oh, no, we can't possibly be a clinical psychologist because there's just too much emotion and distress involved and yeah no you can't escape from what you're meant to be doing it's basically the lesson of all of that your path found you yeah you're doing you're doing
母乳喂养的障碍、缺乏支持，以及随之而来的对心理健康的影响。这正是我们兜了一大圈回到的起点：我最终做了大量关于悲伤、创伤以及因无法达到自己的喂养目标而带来的产后抑郁风险增加的研究，比如无法按预期坚持母乳喂养、经历大量的疼痛和困难。当然，伴随这一切的强烈情绪、悲伤和痛苦是巨大的。所以你看，20岁的我决定：“哦，不，我们绝对不能当临床心理学家，因为这里面涉及的情感和痛苦实在是太多了。”结果证明，你根本无法逃避你命中注定要做的事，这基本上就是这一切给我的教训。你的道路找到了你。是的，你正在做
such worthwhile and worthy work but also what interested in what you said is is something that I experienced a lot in in my burgeoning career and probably still now, too. But it's what unhelpful messages people give you about yourself along the journey. You know, you couldn't possibly do that and you won't do that and you'll never get to there. And perhaps you should try a bit, you know, aim a bit lower. And that's not that useful, is it? No, it's it's a complete red rag to a bull for me, to be honest. As soon as somebody tells me I can't do anything, I'm going to do it. And I'm going to do it 10 times more of what you just told me I can't do. But I was told that so many times. I mean, my PhD supervisors were brilliantly
非常有价值和意义的工作。但我也对你所说的话很感兴趣，这也是我在蓬勃发展的职业生涯中经常经历的，可能到现在也是如此。那就是，在旅程中人们会给你关于你自己的各种无益的评价。“你绝不可能做到那一点”、“你做不到”、“你永远到不了那个高度”。也许你应该尝试把目标放低一点。那其实并没有什么用，对吧？不，说实话，对我来说这就像是红布挑逗公牛。一旦有人告诉我我做不到什么，我偏要去做。而且我要把我做不到的事做得比他们说的多十倍。但我以前听过太多次这种话了。我的博士生导师们给予了极其出色的
supportive, but people around me told me my career was over and I'd never succeed now. And isn't it a shame because I was doing such good PhD work, but I had, you know, I would say I had two and a half babies during my PhD because I was about 20 weeks pregnant at Viva. I just got the corrections in before he was born. And, you know, if anybody is reading this as a PhD student, I actually found that it worked really well, because, well, for my type of PhD anyway, because A, I was conducting research with families, so it actually gave me more accessibility and more credibility.
支持，但周围的人却告诉我我的职业生涯已经结束了，现在绝不可能成功。这不是很遗憾吗？因为我当时在做非常棒的博士研究，但我可以说是“在攻读博士期间生了两个半孩子”，因为我在毕业答辩（Viva）时大约怀孕20周。我赶在孩子出生前把论文修改好了。而且，如果你是以博士生身份在读这篇文章，我实际上发现这种安排效果非常好，因为——至少对我的博士类型来说是这样的，因为第一，我是在与家庭进行研究，这实际上赋予了我更高的可及性和可信度。
But also, I could just fit it around them. I didn't have to be in an office job nine till five every day. so it was actually a one of the easier times in my opinion to actually have them at that point they certainly never stopped me and of course once you have children you you don't really get the option to just stop and not you know carry on you you have to keep working to support them and that's essentially what I did. I just kept going. I wish I could say there was some big strategy with all of this, but it was just persistence, I think, alongside luck, you know, positions coming up at the right time,
而且，我可以在照顾他们之余安排时间。我不必每天朝九晚五地坐在办公室里。所以在我的经验看来，那其实是生孩子相对比较轻松的阶段。他们当然从未阻挡过我的脚步。当然，一旦你有了孩子，你就真的没有选择可以“停下来”而不去继续前行。你必须为了养育他们而继续工作，这基本上就是我所做的。我只是咬牙坚持了下来。我希望我能说这一切背后有什么宏大的战略，但其实只有坚持，再加上运气，比如职位在正确的时机出现，
being able to have the skills of writing easily. So I had lots of publications. So I was getting research positions and then academic posts. But they certainly never stopped me. They helped. I don't think I'd have the career that I have without them, both through the drive to keep going and prove everybody wrong, make sure that they were supported, but also just the huge understanding and access to the area that I was researching. Life happens whilst you're waiting for your psychology career to start doesn't it but actually what you're saying is it really makes your career as well you know I was I remember being in CAMHS placements and things and thinking oh they're gonna say have you got any children and I'm gonna be like no um and I but I definitely
具备能够轻松写作的技能。所以我有很多出版物。于是我得到了研究职位，接着是学术岗位。但他们（指孩子）从未阻挡我。他们反而给予了帮助。如果没有他们，我想我不会拥有今天的职业生涯，这不仅来自于继续前行、向所有人证明自己、确保他们得到支持的驱动力，还来自于对所研究领域的深刻理解和接触。就在你等待心理学职业生涯开始的时候，生活却在悄然发生，不是吗？但实际上，你所表达的意思是，生活经历也真正成就了你的职业生涯。我记得自己曾在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）等机构实习，当时心里想：“哦，他们会不会问‘你有孩子吗’，然后我只能回答‘没有’。”而且我绝对
feel since becoming a mother it's broadened my ability to connect with others and to understand you know I was already pretty much an empath anyway but I really feel that you know becoming a parent and then losing a parent as well has just helped me on so many levels and actually I don't spend all of the sessions crying so you know we do all right we do all right and it sounds yeah it sounds like you actually you know absolutely made hay whilst the sun shone as you were developing your career. Yeah and it just gave me insight into what was missing from a research perspective that I was having these experiences and at the same time I could see the gaps in the literature. And I just I think I was kind of riding a wave at the time that we're talking back 2005, 2006 here.
觉得自从成为母亲后，我与他人建立连接以及理解他人的能力得到了拓宽。我本来就已经相当有同理心了，但我深切地感到，成为父母以及后来经历亲人离世，在许多层面上都对我有所助益。实际上，我并不会把所有咨询时间都用来哭泣，所以我们处理得很好，我们处理得很好。听起来——是的，听起来你在发展职业生涯的同时，确实真正做到了“趁热打铁”。是的，这让我从研究的角度洞察到了缺失的内容。我当时正经历这些体验，与此同时，我也能看出文献中的空白。而且我想我当时只是顺应了时代潮流，我们这里指的是2005年、2006年的事情。
So my eldest is nearly 16. And at the time, there was a kind of gap in the early parenting, midwiferyery infant feeding literature around the psychology of all of this so there was great research around you know breastfeeding from a health professional perspective and you know supporting mothers so in terms of peer support and professional support there was less around some of the core areas of psychology. And it was just kind of really bringing mental health into it. So although there was research around postnatal depression and feeding experiences, there were gaps that I could explore in more depth and take advantage of, is the wrong word, but take advantage of from a research perspective in filling some of those gaps particularly around the lasting emotional impact of not being able to breastfeed and we're taking that further now looking at the emotional experiences and mental health impacts of
所以我的大女儿快16岁了。在当时，早期的育儿、助产以及婴儿喂养文献中，关于这一切背后的心理学研究存在一定的空白。当时有很多从医疗专业人员角度出发的优秀母乳喂养研究（比如在同伴支持和专业支持方面支持母亲），但在心理学的某些核心领域研究较少。这仅仅是将心理健康融入其中的过程。因此，尽管已有关于产后抑郁和喂养体验的研究，但仍存在一些空白，我可以对这些空白进行更深入的探索并加以利用（“利用”可能不是个好词），从研究角度填补其中一些空白，特别是关于无法母乳喂养所带来的持久情感影响。我们现在正在将这一研究进一步推向深入，去关注当婴儿早产或身体不适时，接受捐赠母乳所带来的情感体验和心理健康影响。所以，还有那么多工作要做，这完美地将心理学与非常早期的育儿体验交织在了一起。
receiving donor milk if your baby is premature or unwell so there's there's so much still to be done and it's just a really good overlap of psychology with that really early parenting experiences it really is and actually it raises really valid and important points you know this feeding trauma it's a thing and actually so many of the people i've worked with in adult mental health services women they you know they recount when they were trying to feed their baby and nobody's ever thought to ask them a question but when you look at postnatal depression and you look at how it developed so often it's about that you know you're taking really exhausted women you're giving them false information you're you know shoehorning them to kind of top up their baby and to give food that
确实如此。实际上，它提出了非常有效且重要的问题。这种“喂养创伤”是真实存在的。事实上，在成人心理健康服务中，我合作过的许多女性，她们都会回忆起自己当年尝试喂养婴儿时的经历，却从来没有人想过问她们一个问题。然而，当你审视产后抑郁症及其发展过程时，往往会发现这与此有关：你面对的是极度疲惫的女性，向她们输送错误的信息，把她们硬生生地推向给婴儿“添加配方奶”的做法，提供她们可能并不想要的食物，却不允许母亲们培养对自身喂养能力的信任。这并不是一期旨在宣传“母乳最好”的节目，根本不是。这关乎知情选择，不是吗？以及能够做出选择，拥有支持你的专业人士并为你提供基于实证的建议与指导。
they might not want to give and they're not allowing mothers to develop their own trust in their ability to feed and this you know this isn't supposed to be an episode about breast is best it's not it's about being informed isn't it and actually being able to make choices and having professionals that are supporting you and giving you evidence-based advice and guidance. Yeah and it is about listening to women as well. Whenever I've done research around mental health and infant feeding experiences it's split into two parts so it's about the actual infant feeding experience and not being able to feed your baby in the way you wanted to but then it's about the dismissal and people not listening once that has happened so one of the big issues across birth and early parenting is the tendency for people to say that it doesn't
是的，这也关乎倾听女性的心声。每当我做关于心理健康和婴儿喂养体验的研究时，它都分为两部分：一部分是实际的婴儿喂养体验，以及无法以你想要的方式喂养婴儿的感受；另一部分则是在那之后遭受的漠视以及人们不愿倾听。因此，在分娩和早期育儿过程中，一个普遍存在的问题是人们倾向于说“这根本不重要”。这通常出于善意，比如在经历艰难的分娩后，人们会说：“看，你的宝宝很健康，他就在这儿，没事的。”当然，你是希望听到这些，但这完全无视了你刚刚经历的创伤，就好像你的感受根本不重要一样。而在婴儿喂养方面，如果你是一个非常想母乳喂养却最终未能如愿的人，那是因为你没有得到支持，无法做到原本承诺会发生的事，那么你当然会为此感到悲伤，产生各种各样的情绪。而当人们随后对你说“这根本不重要”时，这是如此轻描淡写和漠视。这并不是对
matter so usually it comes from a good place so it's things like after a difficult birth people will say well look your baby's healthy they're here it's fine and of course you want that but it's completely ignoring the the trauma that you've just been through as if you don't matter and with feeding babies if you're somebody who really wanted to breastfeed and it didn't work out and that's because you weren't supported and you couldn't do what you were promised that would happen then of course you're going to have grief around that you're going to have all sorts of emotions and when people then just tell you it doesn't matter it's it's so dismissive and it's not a judgment of
使用配方奶粉的评判，你也不一定对使用配方奶粉感到不高兴。你可以为宝宝得到喂养并茁壮成长而感到非常高兴，但这件事对你来说依然重要。当这种感受被忽视时，我认为这正是造成长期情感影响的根源，因为你没有机会去处理它，却被告知“这不重要”，于是你只好把它深深埋在心底。当然，它会在后来的阶段爆发出来。这是一种持续的无效化（invalidating），同时却又试图在无效化别人的过程中显得很有帮助。我认为这对我们的听众来说是非常有用的观点：不要太快地粉饰太平，说“一切都很好，你看宝宝多健康，你看你做得多棒”，依然要去做
using formula and you're not necessarily unhappy about using formula you can be very happy that your baby's fed and thriving but it still matters to you and when that's dismissed then I think that's what sets up this long-term emotional impact because you don't get a chance to process it and you're told it doesn't matter so you just bury it down and of course it comes out at later stages it's that constant invalidation whilst actually trying to be quite helpful in the process of accidentally invalidating someone and I think that's really useful stuff for our audience to hold on to you know to not be too quick to smooth things over and say it's all fine because look baby's baby's brilliantly healthy and look what a good job you did you know still still doing
你为了让宝宝健康成长所需要做的事情……但是，是的，听起来你做了一些非常棒的、由用户主导的研究，而且这些是你认识到有必要去做的事情，并带来了非常出色的成果。对于其他有志成为心理学家的年轻人，你有什么建议能帮助他们开启自己的研究工作吗？我认为关键在于：如果你对某件事充满热情，就永远不要放弃，并采取最初的步骤去把它完成。我知道这听起来有点过于简单，但不要让任何人阻止你，也不要让他们对你说那个研究领域不重要。这是我在成长道路上听到的另一类无益的评价。当时至少有两位资深学者（不是在我所在的大学，而是在不同的大学）告诉我，如果我想取得进展、
what you needed to do to get your baby you know healthy and well but um yeah this in terms of it sounds like you've done some really wonderful user-led research but it was you know it was stuff you recognized needed to happen but has led to really brilliant outcomes have you got any advice for how other aspiring psychologists might be able to kickstart their own research efforts? I think it's around just if you've got a passion for something never giving up and just taking those first steps to actually get it done I know that sounds you know kind of simplistic but don't let anybody stop you or tell you that that research area doesn't matter That's one of the other unhelpful messages that I've had along the way is that at least two very senior academics, not at my university, but at different universities, told me that if I wanted to progress,
如果我想获得长期的学术职位、如果我未来想成为教授，我就必须停止关注婴儿喂养和早期育儿这个狭窄的领域，转而去做更广泛的事情。而我的想法是：“不，我才不呢，你太荒谬了，走开吧。”莫（Mo）当时用的语气可能比这稍微礼貌一点，但你知道的，他们再次向我证明——请不要告诉我我做不到什么，因为那只会激起我去做这件事的决心。但如果你认为某件事很重要，那就值得从这种小规模的研究开始，它会逐渐积累。你总得从某处开始。而那第一项研究将会是一次学习经历，其中会有错误，这很正常，这本来就是研究的一部分。
if I wanted a permanent academic post, if I ever wanted to be a professor in the future, I had to stop focusing on this niche area of infant feeding and early parenting and do something far broader and I thought no I don't you're daft go away Mo's been slightly less polite version than that but you know they again please don't tell me what I can't do because that's just going to encourage me to do it but if you think something is important it's it's worth starting with with that small scale research and it will build. You've got to start somewhere. And that first piece of research is going to be a learning experience. It's going to have mistakes in it. That's just normal. That's a part of research.
但这关乎随着时间的推移建立起整体的图景。你可能觉得只是一项小研究，对广阔的世界来说或许并不引人注目，但对其他人来说可能非常迷人，他们会看到它并在此基础上继续深入。建立合作需要时间，但这是在播下最初的种子，我想，并且要有信心迈出第一步，说：“这是重要的事情。”任何人都能做到吗，艾米？所以如果人们在听节目时想：“我之前以为自己需要一个研究导师或一个真正的大人来帮我完成这个过程”，或者任何人都可以尝试去做研究伦理审查、开始做一些有趣且有用的事情吗？是的，我对这种“大人的事情”不太了解，老实说我还没遇到过什么大人。我想如果我们一直在等一个大人的出现，
But it's about building up that overall picture over time and what might just be a small study and you think isn't might not be fascinating to the wider world probably is fascinating to somebody else and they'll see it and they'll build on that and collaborations take time but it's planting those first seeds I guess and having the confidence to take that first step and say this is important stuff can anyone do it Amy so if people are listening and thinking I kind of thought I needed like a research supervisor or a real grown-up to help me through this process or can anyone kind of look to do you know research ethics and get started and do something that's interesting and useful yeah I don't know about this grown-up stuff I haven't met any to be honest I think if we wait around for a grown-up
那我们要等很久很久。我认为研究伦理真的非常重要，所以关键在于弄清楚你要从哪个伦理委员会获得批准。如果你在临床实践中工作，并且能看到大学里有学者在做研究，不妨给他们发电子邮件，与他们取得联系，并说：“我刚好有一个非常有趣的想法。”因为我们非常喜欢合作，尤其是与身处临床一线的实践者合作。我不会说我坐在象牙塔里，因为我没有，我一直通过社交媒体与父母交流，但我并不在一线工作，我没有那样的实际经验。所以这关乎认识到你所拥有的经验的价值，并在没有权限接触伦理委员会的情况下开展合作，所以请务必主动伸出援手。
we're going to be waiting a long time I think you know research ethics is is really important so it's around working out where you're going to get permission from a ethics committee it's worth contacting if you're working out in clinical practice and you can see an academic working at a university email them get in touch with them and say I've just got this really interesting idea because we love collaborations particularly with people who are working out they're in practice you know I'm not going to say I sit in an ivory tower because I don't I work with you know talk to parents via social media all the time but I'm not working in practice I don't have that experience so it's about recognizing the value of what you do have and working in collaboration if you haven't got
是的，看看这些绝佳的建议。把它输入谷歌学术（Google Scholar），看看谁在你的大致领域内做研究，然后与他们取得联系。老实说，这简直是黄金法则。因为我认为当你走上诸如在简历中填写“相关经验”板块的道路时，感觉会像是：“在这个部门里根本没有人做研究，所以我现在无法在简历上勾选这一项。”但实际上，你可以做到，因为你可以在此之外开展工作，或者你可以并行推进。绝对可以。或者联系一所拥有你所热衷领域的研究所的大学，看看你是否可以作为名誉研究助理参与其中，
access to an ethics committee so please do reach out yeah look at such wonderful advice put it into google scholar and see who's doing research vaguely in your area and get in touch with them that's honestly that is like golden advice because i think when you're sort of going down a route where you're doing like the you know you're doing the relevant experience um section of your cv it can feel like well no one's really doing any research in this department so i can't really tick that part of my CV off right now. But actually, you can because you can do stuff outside of that or you can do it in parallel. Absolutely. Or contact a university that has a research team in your area that you're passionate about and see if you can do some research, you know, as an honorary research assistant
协助他们开展研究。我不敢说每个人都会百分之百答应，但我们确实会雇用一些人签订短期研究合同，让他们在培训之余做一点研究，这样你就能掌握与此相关的全套研究学习和知识。你可以主动询问是否可以在某个研究项目上进行实习，只要去联系并询问就行，因为那是对话的开始。确实如此。而且你永远不知道，答案很可能是“愿意”。这不仅对你大有裨益，对你所研究的群体来说也是如此。艾米，大家会非常喜欢你今天所说的话，这真的会极大地增强人们的信心。因为当你申请任何心理学分支的志愿时，
alongside them. You know, I can't say that everybody will always say yes, but certainly we have people who we employ on short-term research contracts to do a little bit of research around their training and you then have, you know access to all the the research learning and knowledge that goes alongside it um ask if you can do a placement on a a research project you know they're just get in contact and ask because you know that's the beginning of the conversation it really is and you know you never know the answer might well be yes um and you know that can be really useful for you but also the populations that you're researching people are gonna love what you've what you've said today amy it's gonna really boost people's confidence you know because
你会收到一份反馈表——我不知道你是否曾申请过任何心理学分支的培训，但你会收到反馈表，上面会详细列出你身上有什么问题，为什么你的申请没有成功。比如：需要更多样化的临床经验、更多相关的临床经验、学术背景需要加强。人们经常听到的是学术方面存在不足，而我往往不知从何下手。所以今天你的话会让大家觉得极其有用。谢谢。哦，太好了。请务必多给我们讲讲你的“书宝宝”们，你都涵盖了哪些领域，人们又该如何买到这些书？
when you're applying for whatever branch of psychology is that you're aspiring to you know you get the feedback form um i don't know if you ever have got around to applying for whatever branch of psychology it is that you're aspiring to, you know, you get the feedback form. I don't know if you ever got around to applying for anything like for clinical, but you get it broken down into what's wrong about you. You know, why your application didn't make, you know, more. So it's more varied clinical experience, more relevant clinical experience. Academic stuff needs strengthening. And so often people are saying it's the academic one actually and I don't feel I don't know where to begin so people will really really find your words so incredibly useful today thank you oh good let me please do tell us some more about your your
我得好好想想它们都是什么了。我们从2016年的《揭秘母乳喂养》开始，这本书刚刚进行了更新，因为过去五年里这个领域发生了太多的变化。关于这本书，还有一个关于坚持不懈的故事。因为我最初是在与另一家出版公司洽谈写这本书的事宜。他们实际上主动找到我，让我提议写这本书。但当他们把提案提交给高层管理人员时，他们的某位老板却说：“没人会读一本关于这个的书，这卖不出去。”所以当然，他们不得不回来对我说：“很抱歉，我们不能出版你的书。”而我当时不得不写……你知道的，“没有人会愿意看，我永远写不出书，也没有人会出版我的作品”。
book babies um and you know what what areas you cover and how people can get hold of copies? I've got to remember what they are now. We started with Brass Feeding Uncovered back in 2016, which has just had an update because so much has gone on in the area in the last five years. And there's another story about perseverance with that as well, because I was initially in discussions with another publishing company to write that. And they actually approached me and asked me to propose this book. But when they took it to the higher levels, their kind of boss person turned around and said, no one's going to read a book on that. It's not going to sell. So of course, they had to come back to me and say, sorry, we can't
谢天谢地，过了几天我重新振作起来，把它重新投给了 Pinter & Martin 出版社，他们说：“没问题，我们来出版，太棒了。”所以这是这一切的开端。这又是关于拒绝的一个重要教训：拒绝是学术界和心理学家培训过程中很正常的一部分。关键在于你如何面对拒绝，这并不是对你個人的批评，而只是体制本身的问题。从那以后——《揭秘母乳喂养》全部聚焦于女性在母乳喂养时面临的身体、心理、社会和经济层面的障碍。接下来的书是《为什么开始添加辅食很重要》（Why Starting Solids Matters）。
publish your book. And you know, I had to write, write you know no one's ever gonna I'm never gonna write a book I can't write and no one's ever gonna publish me um thankfully I pulled myself together after a few days and resubmitted it to Pinter and Martin who said yeah sure we'll publish that great so that was the start of that and it's just an important lesson again in in rejection is a normal part I think kind of a key message throughout academia and through psychologist training is you are going to get rejected it's how you deal with it that matters it's not a criticism of you it's just the system so from there so breastfeeding and covered is all about the barriers that women face when they're breastfeeding from a physical, psychological, social, economic level. Then it was why starting solids matters.
这本书探讨了围绕向婴儿引入辅食的所有研究证据和指导原则。同样，它是为了给这个领域带来研究证据，而不是各种迷思。再之后是《积极母乳喂养》（Positive Breastfeeding），这是一本母乳喂养指南。当时这稍微超出了我的舒适区，因为这是一本充满基于实证的实用建议的书。它将证据转化为对父母的实用创新或支持，但我不得不淡化参考文献，直到现在我对此依然不太习惯。我体内的研究员和学生本能要求每一行都要有参考文献。但当然，对于直接写给父母的书，你不能这样做。尽管你知道，他们并不需要成千上万条参考文献，
So it's around all the research evidence and guidance around introducing solids to babies. So it's again, it's bringing some research evidence rather than myths to this area. From then, it was positive breastfeeding, which is a guide to breastfeeding. So something that was slightly out of my comfort zone at the time, it was kind of writing a book that was full of evidence based practical advice. So turning the evidence into practical innovations or support for parents, but I had to back off the references, which I'm still never very comfortable with. You know, the researcher and student in me has to reference every line. But of course, you can't do that with a book directly for parents. Although, you know, they don't need thousands and thousands of references.
他们需要的是一个拥抱。噢，天哪，接下来是什么……《知情选择最好》（Informed is Best）。《知情选择最好》的诞生源于互联网上的又一场争论，起因是关于研究证据被错误使用以及各种迷思满天飞。这本书旨在面向父母、健康专业人士以及任何想要更多了解如何真正理解研究的人，揭露媒体使用的各种把戏、资金资助中的偏见，以及当我们面对媒体头条和研究报告时，如何学会透过现象看本质。我们还有《母乳喂养、悲伤与创伤》（Breastfeeding, Grief, and Trauma），也就是我刚才谈到的那本书，它旨在认可和肯定女性在无法
They need a hug. Oh, gosh, what was next um informed is best so informed is best came about after yet another argument on the internet about how research evidence was being used incorrectly and myths flying about so it's it's aimed at parents and health professionals and anybody who wants to know more about understanding research, really, and all the tricks that the media play, and the biases in funding, and how basically we need to read behind the lines when we look at media headlines and research studies. We have Breastfeeding, Grief, and Trauma, which was the book that I was talking about earlier, which is, you know, just validating women's experiences around not being
母乳喂养时的经历，并为如何获得更多相关支持提供一些思路。接下来是什么？我想那是《第一年育儿》这本书。我们来聊聊《第一年育儿》，这是一本厚厚的指南，但它的设计初衷是一本可以随翻随读的书。所以它基本上涵盖了早期育儿的所有心理学知识：照顾你自己、你的心理健康、身体康复、为人父母的各种压力、人际关系、重返工作岗位。里面有一个章节是关于新生儿重症监护室里的宝宝的，对吗？是的，是的。所以内容包括：如果你的宝宝在新生儿重症监护室，或者有残疾，或者你的情况发生了任何改变，我们要如何支持你？我们有专门针对单亲父母的章节，
able to breastfeed and offering some ideas for how you can get more support with that what's next I think that's the first year of parenting book so let's talk about the first year of parenting which is it's a big guide but it's it's meant to be a book that you dip in and out of so it's it's basically all the psychology really of early parenting so looking after yourself your mental health your physical recovery all the pressures of becoming a parent relationships going back to work kind of a guide there's a section in there about um but babies in uh early neonatal units as well isn't there yes yeah so what happens you know supporting you if your baby's in neonatal care or has a disability or you know just your circumstances have changed in any way we've got sections for single parents
里面应有尽有，可以说是第一年育儿的全面指南。然后我们还有——《医学专业母乳喂养支持指南》（A Guide to Supporting Breastfeeding for the Medical Profession），这本书实际上是面向医学专业人士的，是一本经过编辑的教科书。里面收录了许多优秀作者的文章，提供了大量信息。编写这本书是为了弥补医学研究培训中关于母乳喂养和婴儿喂养的空白，因为许多医生其实并没有接受过太多这方面的培训。所以我们只是试图提供一本基于实证的指南。我们接下来写了什么？然后我们有了《让我们聊聊如何喂养宝宝》（Let's Talk About Feeding Your Baby），这是一本较短的书，是关于母乳喂养、配方奶喂养和添加辅食的精简指南。我确信我漏掉了一本……不管怎样，接着我们有了更新版的《揭秘母乳喂养》，然后是最新的《新冠宝宝》（Covid Babies）。这本书探讨了所有
um it's got everything in there i'll guide to that first year then we have oh a guide to supporting breastfeeding for the medical profession which is actually aimed at medical professionals and it's a edited textbook so it's got just lots of great authors in it all providing lots of information it was aimed at medics due to the gap in the research training around breastfeeding and infant feeding that many doctors don't actually have much training around it. So we were just trying to provide an evidence based guide. What are we up to? We then have let's talk about feeding your baby, which is a shorter book, which is a shorter guide to breastfeeding formula feeding and introducing solids i'm sure i've missed one here anyway then we have the one you get the updated breastfeeding uncovered and then we've got the newest one which is covid babies which is looking at all the
研究证据，关注大流行和封锁对怀孕、分娩以及早期育儿产生的影响，并真正帮助人们认可这段时期的经历。因为这段时间实在是太艰难了，然而许多父母却觉得自己无法抱怨，因为我们显然身处全球危机和大流行之中。但这本书真正呼吁的是：现在需要更多的支持以及支持服务，来帮助父母们处理他们所经历的一切、错失的一切，以及他们可能经历的护理模式的变changes。我想就是这些了。干得好，因为说实话，我读过其中九本中的三本，但我绝对要去抢购一本《新冠宝宝》。抱歉……但这些都是重要的事情，而且你做得非常出色，我经常向别人推荐你的作品。
research evidence for the impact that the pandemic and lockdowns has had upon pregnancy and birth and early parenting and just really helping validate experiences during this time because it's been so so tough yet lots of parents have felt that they can't complain because obviously we're in a global crisis and pandemic but it's really about calling for more support now and support services to help parents process what they've been through and what they've missed out on and changes to the care that they might have had I think that's it well done because honestly there I've read three out of three out of the nine but I'm definitely going to grab me a code of babies but I'm sorry um but you know it's important stuff and you're doing it so well and I recommend you so often
关于大流行和封锁对怀孕、分娩以及早期育儿影响的研究证据，确实有助于证实这段时间的经历，因为这段经历实在是太艰难了。然而，许多父母觉得他们不能抱怨，因为显然我们正处于全球危机和大流行之中，但真正需要做的是呼吁现在提供更多支持和支持服务，以帮助父母消化他们所经历的事情、错过的东西以及他们可能经历过的护理变化。我认为就是这样，做得好，因为说实话，在九本中我已经读了三本，但我绝对会去拿一本《Babies》，对不起，嗯，但你知道，这些都是重要的东西，你做得非常好，我经常向别人推荐你。
and you know I'm sorry for fangirling all over you um in this podcast episode but you know um yeah you're doing really good stuff what's the best way or multiple ways that people can get hold of copies of your books um so I have a website um professor amy brown.co.uk novel uh website there but it's got everything on there so it's got well i'm trying to put all copies of my research articles on there but that's that's taking a while because there are over a hundred of them and i you know i get i wander off in the middle of the task um i've got loads of blog articles I've written. I've got videos to watch of presentations that I've done. And then there's just a little shop on there where you can buy signed copies and packages of books. I should say as well that Lindsay Hookway and I have got a new
你知道的，在这个播客节目里我对你各种疯狂崇拜，真是不好意思，不过你知道的，嗯，是的，你正在做非常棒的事情。大家有什么最佳途径或多种途径可以买到你的书呢？嗯，我有一个网站，professorsamybrown.co.uk，上面有我的小说，但上面什么都有，嗯，我正试图把我的所有研究文章都放到上面去，不过这需要花点时间，因为有一百多篇，而且你知道的，我经常在做到一半时就分心了。我有很多写过的博客文章，还有我做过的演讲视频可以观看。然后上面还有一个小商店，你可以在那里买到签名版的书和图书套装。我还想说的是，琳赛·胡克韦和我有一本新书
book coming out towards the end of March, which is actually putting together all our experience of writing books and writing for the public. So look out for that one as well, because if you're interested in writing and communicating and aren't sure where to start, it's some guidance around the practicalities, but also dealing with criticism and imposter syndrome and rejection and all those things that we go through so we're hoping that will be really useful as well so useful absolutely and it might well be we'll discuss when to schedule this at this episode but if it would be useful to schedule this one around when that's uh when that's going to be published then we can absolutely do that but you know you've
将在三月底左右出版，这本书实际上汇集了我们写书以及为公众写作的所有经验。所以也请关注那一本，因为如果你对写作和沟通感兴趣，却又不知道从哪里开始，它会提供一些关于实际操作的指导，同时也会处理批评、冒名顶替综合征、拒绝以及我们所经历的所有这些事情，所以我们希望这本书也会非常有用。非常有用，绝对的。我们可能会讨论这期节目什么时候排期播出，如果能把这期节目的播出时间安排在它即将出版的时候，那当然最好不过了。不过你知道的，与你交谈
been such an inspiration to talk to you've you've never think i thought you would be um but you know you you know you're you are doing what so many people um would would be striving to do and you've given them some really tangible steps for how to do it but also you know for anyone working with any human during their aspiring psychology journey you've given us some really useful pointers to consider and the impact that has on them and their ability to to be a parent or a child for that matter in in the world right now thank you i think my main message is just don't give up just keep going it's tough yeah keep going yeah thank you so much for your time Amy thank you so much for listening um please do come and connect with me on my socials
真的是一种激励，你完全不像我想象的那样……不过你知道的，你正在做许多人梦寐以求的事情，你为他们提供了一些切实可行的步骤，告诉他们如何去实现，而且对于任何在追求心理学职业道路上与人类打交道的人，你也给我们提供了一些非常实用的指导原则，让我们去思考这些原则对他们产生的影响，以及他们在当今世界中作为父母或孩子的这种能力。谢谢你，我想我的主要信息就是：不要放弃，坚持下去。是的，这很难，坚持下去。非常感谢你抽出时间，埃米。非常感谢大家的收听，请一定要来我的社交平台上和我联系
linkedin dr marianne trent youtube good thinking psychological services facebook good thinking Thinking Psychological Services, Facebook Good Thinking Psychological Services, Twitter Good Thinking PS1 and Instagram Dr. Marianne Trent. Thank you again for being part of my world and for listening right to the end. We've just got a little bit coming up about the Compassionate Q&A series and then you can enjoy the jingle. Take care. And like I said, if you'd like to get involved with your own story for the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, then do check out the details in the show notes for how you can request more information. But if you head to my website, which is goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and then head to my books there will be information there for you being well supported during any interview season is so important I have therefore
领英搜索Dr Marianne Trent，YouTube搜索Good Thinking Psychological Services，Facebook搜索Good Thinking Psychological Services，推特搜索Good Thinking PS1，以及Instagram搜索Dr Marianne Trent。再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分，并一直收听到底。接下来我们会有关于“富有同情心的问答”系列的一小段内容，之后大家就可以欣赏片头曲了。保重。就像我说的，如果你想带着自己的故事加入“有抱负的心理学家集体”，请查看节目简介中的详细信息，了解如何获取更多信息。如果你访问我的网站 goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后点击我的书籍，那里会有相关信息。在任何面试季都能得到良好的支持是非常重要的，因此我
planned some compassionate question and answer support sessions for you. You are absolutely welcome to come along to all of them. Some of them, none of them. No need to book. And here are the dates for you. Monday, the 28th of February from 7.30pm. Monday, the 21st of March, 7.30pm. Monday, the 4th of April, 7.30pm. And Monday, the 9th of May, 7.30pm.
为你计划了一些富有同情心的问答支持环节。非常欢迎你参加所有这些环节，参加其中一部分，或者不参加都可以，无需预约。以下是给你的具体日期：2月28日星期一晚上7:30，3月21日星期一晚上7:30，4月4日星期一晚上7:30，以及5月9日星期一晚上7:30。
And they will all be live streaming via my socials, which includes Twitter, YouTube, LinkedIn and Facebook. So you can absolutely pick your favourite platform and they'll all be available on replay as well. Hope you find it so useful and I will look forward to catching up with some of you then. Take care. With this podcast that you'll see, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories there are to get there and there's no
它们都将通过我的社交平台进行直播，包括推特、YouTube、领英和Facebook。所以你绝对可以选择你最喜欢的平台，而且所有这些直播都将提供回放。希望你会觉得非常有用，我也期待到时与其中一些人交流。保重。通过这个播客节目，你会发现你正在通往获得资格的道路上。这里是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康实习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现书中关于实现目标的所有不同故事都非常有趣，而且成为一名心理学家
perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并没有什么完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，让我知道我并没有做错，也减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下了。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。